nato secretary general jens stoltenberg
has said that turkey's security concerns
over swedish and finnish nato membership
are legitimate
the two nordic countries applied to join
the alliance last month in light of
russia's war on ukraine but turkey's
president recep tayyip erdogan has
raised objections accusing them of
backing kurdish opposition groups ankara
considers terrorist organizations
in helsinki the message to ankara was
clear nato is listening
welcome we are working hard
with our nato ally turkey turkey and
also with finland and sweden to address
those issues that turkey has raised and
these are legitimate concerns this is
about terrorism it's about weapons
exports
the finnish president also stressed that
talks were ongoing but neither hinted at
any progress
turkey's president erdogan took his nato
allies by surprise last month when he
said he would block finland and sweden's
membership bids
accusing them of harbouring people
linked to the kurdistan workers party
the pkk which is listed as a terrorist
organization in both
countries turkey also accuses sweden of
backing the people's defence units in
northern syria ankara regards the mainly
kurdish militia as an offshoot of the
pkk a view not shared by its nato allies
the two nordic countries placed turkey
under an arms export embargo after it
launched an offensive against the group
in 2019.
erdogan has said that embargo is another
obstacle on their road to nato
membership
and for more on this we're joined by our
dwu correspondent terry schultz in
brussels uh terry
secretary general stoltenberg says he
has understanding for turkey's concerns
in this dispute what does that mean
yes that that's what he said and uh
stoltenberg has offered himself as a
mediator in this dispute so he is
walking a very fine line uh he needs to
make sure not to antagonize turkey
further so that it will put up even more
resistance to finland and sweden joining
at the same time particularly as a
fellow nordic leader stoltenberg doesn't
really believe i'm certain that finland
and sweden are
knowingly harboring terrorists or
exporting weapons to to groups
considered a terrorist by the european
union and by both of these countries
themselves the pkk so we need to listen
carefully to what stoltenberg said he
said turkey's concerns about terrorism
and about weapons exports to terrorist
groups are legitimate concerns he did
not go so far as to say he thinks either
of these two countries are doing that
but again with turkey already being a
member and with all 30 allies needing to
approve the accession of finland and
sweden he needs to make sure to be
listening to ankara to make sure turkey
feels like it it's being taken into
consideration at the same time he needs
to keep up hopes in finland and sweden
that this bold move they've taken to
apply for membership in the alliance are
kept alive and just to get into the
details here between the two countries
turkey seems more opposed to sweden
joining than finland tomorrow
stoltenberg meets with the swedish prime
minister what what do we expect there
that's true sweden does seem to be more
of a bull's-eye for turkey than than
finland does and the finnish president
today expressed his his surprise more
than once in that press conference that
turkey is opposing his country he said
that he'd received assurances many many
times that uh turkey supported finnish
membership uh so he's clearly very
disappointed in that president sauling
tomorrow in sweden you're likely to hear
secretary general stoltenberg say more
of the same that turkish concerns need
to be taken into account that he is
going to be discussing with the three
countries intensively how you can
resolve this um but it truly does seem
to be a standoff right now
and look i know you don't want a crystal
ball gaze but does it seem like there's
a possible compromise
there has to be a pos a compromise
because everybody in nato including
turkey knows that finland and sweden
would be very very
useful additions to the alliance that
they would make nato stronger and that's
in everyone's interest turkey i think at
its heart is not opposed to finland and
sweden joining nato it simply wants to
extract the most that it can
out of out of this process and it has
the power to do so right now everyone
hopes this will be resolved that the
accession negotiations can be opened by
the summit in madrid the end of this
month
okay terry schultz reporting for us from
brussels thanks so much
you